[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast i'm
here with rafael pickle we're gonna be
discussing gary vaynerchuk youtube work
ethic I think you're gonna get a lot of
golden nuggets so stay tuned until the
very end good to have you with me okay
Sammy well thank you very much it's a
pleasure thanks for having me on your
podcast did we've been talking about
doing a podcast together forever
yes almost forever so I think one of the
reasons I wanted you on the show was
because you've massively helped with our
business you've you've done awesome
awesome person a lot of knowledge you've
worked with great people before like
Gary Vaynerchuk and haven't you worked
didn't you work that Warren Buffett's
event yeah I did some social media
content for he's one of his companies
Berkshire Hathaway fantastic so he's
great really good to have you on the
show tell me what you have tattooed on
your arm oh I will make it public
nothing not many people have seen it but
exclusive content what what does it say
on your honor so if yours can see it it
says that's great work harder yeah what
did you get that tattooed on your arm
why why yeah it as a reminder because I
obviously was aware of that and I was
aware about you know as a thought in my
mind or as a written to-do item on my
to-do list whether it's on a phone or a
piece of paper but things like that you
know you we either lost them or you know
when we make some sort of resolutions or
we think about like when we make a
mistake and we then things go okay for a
while then we do the similar mistakes
again so I thought this is really
important to me so I want to have it you
know and the best way to have it almost
forever is to tattoo it yeah why didn't
why I put these words because I believe
this is the only thing that we can
control because I just over the years
when you know just living the life
running the business but just living the
life I found out that there are so many
things in the world that we cannot
control like politics like weather like
others people opinions yeah what we can
control is the amount of work we put
into whatever we do yeah and it could be
work in a business sense but it could be
as well the rest and like taking care of
family so if we work harder on anything
that we want I could join you
when we first met because I called you
out on that remember when I said when
you're an old man with your grandkids
all around and you and you're enjoying
time with family you've worked hard and
now you've got properties all over the
world and people working for you and
everything are you really gonna want to
look at your arm and it's a work harder
and you actually said you actually said
actually yes because even if I'm working
hard on building relationships with my
family and stuff it doesn't necessarily
just mean business
exactly I couldn't argue with that yeah
and there's only video we can control
because we can control the number of
hours we put into something so where it
is work hassle or if it's in a leisure
we can work harder on an arresting I
found out that we don't know as a
humanity how to rest I know what you
think about that but just we know we're
stressed as humanity yeah and then we
always want to do something like in the
past when I had a minute of free time
also looking either for a phone or a
laptop because I didn't want to stay
alone yeah myself yeah and over the
years I've learned to do it ya know did
you experience that yeah you know what I
like to have massages
okay because and I like to have a 90
minute massage because after about 45
minutes that's when I really get relaxed
and then if after 60 votes they go okay
I'm like oh no I just entered that
period of deep relaxation so 90 minute
massage or completely you know tune off
from from the whole world and then I'll
come out and it also can new person
different pace different me so I
regularly like to have 90-minute
massages have you ever tried an
acupuncture is that where they put pins
in yeah like in the house micronesia
only for therapy though when I broke my
knee yeah I had like probably two dozen
sessions like that and the beginning is
a bit weird my friends always try and
get me to have some weird stuff lots for
all the friends that have when they put
those things and below that I've never
done only that stuff just nice deep
relaxing massages but is that kind of a
massage a way for you to possibly deal
with stress
there is no masking is because as we are
talking today literally probably less
24 hours ago there was extremely
unfortunate thing one of the no NBA
legends has died an accident Kobe Bryant
unfortunately with his daughter and that
shows us like when I shared this news
with my with my father-in-law who's
sitting next to me and I said on social
media first yeah I was like you know do
you know this name we said yeah he does
he knew and he mentioned how he probably
has millions or billions and
unfortunately this thing happened to him
so at the end of the day we all end up
in the same place depending on you know
what we believe in but I ask you this
question because especially in Western
world you know Europe Europe we know the
UK and America we are stressed because
there's so much going on how do you deal
with stress how do you keep positive I
mean yeah I mean terrible to help tell
the news I found out as well just just
to die and well I actually didn't know I
didn't know him super well like I wasn't
a big follower with my wife and unless
she was a real big fan and she actually
cried when when she when she read the
news and all both Hoban and it was fake
news you know and then you google it and
then you know and it is it's it's it's a
massive tragedy a tragedy and I guess
you write it kind of it makes you
realize that actually every day every
breath is a gift and sometimes when you
go to work when you're going about your
business and even if you have your own
business it can still almost become like
a wheel of like almost a rat race not
not a financial rat race but just in a
bit you will rat race so I mean to
answer your question you know what I
only work want to feel like it but I
just feel like it all the time mm-hmm so
if I if I don't feel like working I'm
genuinely just not parents the office in
fact even remember the last week and I
was really tired at a really long week
and we had a podcast I just mentioned I
said did you mind relieving me from
releasing me from the commitment because
I didn't feel like coming into the
office I was tired I was groggy
I wasn't I wasn't ill but I was just I
just thought I just need just a day to
just be at home recharge and so if I
feel like that then I just I'll just
I'll recharge in the same way that you
have to recharge your phone yeah you
charge you find if you
you don't burn out I think in the same
way although we're really driven to
succeed and grow the business you do
need to take time out but where do you
find the balance between that because of
this stage you you run you know a few
businesses and you're financially free
you've got teams working for you so you
can you can afford that
you know either for a while or forever
but in most situations most people
cannot most people have day jobs or run
their own business so where do you find
a balance between relaxing but not being
lazy and then hustle but not you know
not killing yourself with work like did
you I'm sure you thought about that
because maybe going back to the you know
to your beginnings and I wanted to ask
you this question you know how did you
start where you firstly appeared online
I know the YouTube is a huge thing for
you but for the first three six months
12 months you have team of people know
exactly you know it's just me okay so
for me personally my problem is never
have been never and is not that I'm lazy
so I'll never my problem will be all
work so hard because I'm so addicted to
succeeding and I love property you know
love mm-hmm this media channel is that I
work so hard that I'll neglect every
other part of life like holidays and
family and so so for me if I don't feel
like working it's like oh my gosh I
don't feel my work and I'm gonna enjoy
being well that's weird
yeah so so in terms of what your
question was
yeah and how to find a balance between
and maybe how a person who cannot afford
to have few days off can find this
balance because we we're always busy yet
maybe you know I know we have thoughts
on that yeah I think when I mean in the
Bible it says God worked six days and
rested on the seventh so you know I
don't know where we got this to day work
week from I think we're the lazy people
added a second a second day maybe two
errands I think work really hard six
days and then have one day off that
should be a general principle so for me
and I even tell all the staff that I
don't let the team work on Sundays we
don't run events on Sundays and even
even people that high up in the
organization directors and stuff like I
work I won't ever expect anybody to do
something on Saturday I'm sorry someday
because you do need you do need one day
off a week I think and then the rest of
the way you can do you want yeah I do
agree it's a today morning I so
interesting post on Instagram and let me
just quote it it was it was opposed by
Chase Jarvis his and the preneur
photographer a famous guy he said rest
better work harder love more repeat
which is very interesting which is rest
better and I you know I for some reason
I just believe in that not only
interesting but in a like you know the
mental and psychological side and in
things like karma I mean obviously what
we have in common one of the things we
have in common is is market marketing
and the lightest you know video editing
tricks and social media stuff like that
but I think that this is my opinion this
at least the second step like the first
should be the mindset you know the way
why we wake up in the morning and and
how to do that so I just you know things
like karma I think it's it's something
which is underappreciated in today's
world like how much attention do you put
into when you teach people when you do
seminars or one to one on a mindset
versus like tactics on how to find a
property what was the balance yeah great
question I mean I mean when I'm teaching
I think I think it has to be a mixture
of both because if I teach people how to
find deals and give them all the
technical side of things but without the
confidence and the environment to
actually do it then you might as well
read a book yeah so our training
programs in your note because you've
been what we do is we create an
environment where it feels normal to
take massive action and then that way
we'll teach our teach something then
I'll do it and they can watch me
and then I'll give opportunity for my
students to do as well so it's kind of a
mixture between doing and learning and
the dooming bit is mindset because
they've already got the information but
some people even though okay here's a
script here's the most agents phone
number call them up do it okay I know
what to do I'm not they do it now I do
want to get honey no no no yeah and
they're not that's why I have to give a
motivational piece yeah look and then
they let me sleep it's a mindset so I
think PD and B day personal development
business development go hand in hand and
I also think now that's the quiet it's a
great quote and if you if you focus on
loving people then you will sleep well
because you're doing everything from a
good place and sometimes people don't
sleep well I'll give you an example with
exercise if I've got an exercise routine
coming up and I've got Marvin's popping
over to make me lift weights do crazy
stuff I could if I let myself dread it
for hours because I think in three hours
has come in and I'm thinking about it
I'm thinking about a thing but the
excess of the workouts forty five
minutes I can make it four hours and 45
minutes by thinking about it forever or
I can just relax and then when he comes
then just go do it and in the same way I
think that with work like when I'm
sleeping I'm not thinking about work I'm
not thinking about what I'm going to do
these calls me when I'm sleeping I'm
just sleeping I get home
I'll go to stairs I'll chat with my wife
will ever dance for watch a movie oh I
am genuinely just switched off and then
I'm sleeping and lastly I sleep eight
hours a day and I don't wake up in
between I always sleep like a baby and
then I wake up and then I'll start my
day yeah so I think it's a great quote
yeah if I'm talking two quotes I'm gonna
let me read a crayon because I had gone
oh I saw something really interesting
which was a quote by Kobe Bryant and
although he's passed on we all know that
his legacy will always remained I think
this this just shows his I mean he was
41 I think when he sadly died keeps so
much he says this he says I have nothing
in common with lazy people who blame
others for their lack of success great
things come from hard work and
perseverance no excuses and I just think
that's such a fitting you know even on
your arm work
yeah because we can control the history
I mean I well experienced that you know
I think a life taught me that you know
currently being in my you know I still
like to say early but more of a mid 30s
let's make it early thirties yeah no I I
started my my journey which was with
self development around you know ten
fifteen years ago I wanted to do some
seminars went to see Anthony Robbins and
just did some development training and I
think I've spent you know probably
hundreds or thousands of hours and and
pounds on that but what I found later
that it's the life that is the the
biggest teacher because you know and
that's probably something similar that
you did when you go and do something
when you experienced think whether it's
personal from your family or just beep
on street or whether it's business it
just teaches you gives you experience
and then you realize what matters people
say when you learn to drive when you
really learn to drive is half the apache
test mm-hmm so you did theory and then
you might think you know all and then
you get in the car you think whoa and
you actually do it and you learn and
then you actually test and then you
really learn in the same way I agree you
can read the books then you attend the
seminars and actually do it but then
without the real-life experience you
can't replace that so but I think that
sometimes if you just rely only on that
and you skip the class you skip the book
then it's going to end up costing you a
lot more in mistakes than it would have
done in education okay that's true so it
has to go no both ways that's why like
being great today in what we do in our
in our expertise but is teaching
investing property in my case in a
social media marketing content marketing
it's a this is kind of a given we have
to be we have to be good great to get
somewhere but in the next level for me
is the the way an ability to speak to
another person you know emotional
intelligence I think that's really
important I know we talked about you
know quite a bit about that but that's
no I think there is not we don't say
enough about about that it just
well the reason I took you know got you
on I know you're freelance but brought
you in are not big capacitor yeah you
were coming in for three hours
for a week no you were in the office
every day yeah and you have been um but
was not big just because of your scale
very skilled videographer very skilled
market I could I could see that but even
more importantly than that it was
actually your attitude your positivity
your leadership skills because I know
that that would rub off on the whole
team and he has in fact you have a
tattoo this is work harder now path
who's filming what does your tattoo say
do come on it was inspired was inspired
come on
did you nobody's that's it yeah okay
well even if it wasn't inspired by it's
very similar mindset but know what those
even just the mindset like your
attitudes definitely rubbed up onto it
but you know what though just just just
I think you're having good people having
good people it rubs off and if you have
good people in your team it because of
what other people even thought I would
say environment is more important than
scale environment is more important than
well power hmm environments the most
important thing and the way to get a
good environment is to get good people
around you angry and in the same way
that a bad apple ruins the bunch a good
apple lifts the rest up mm-hmm so you
know and it's been great seeing that you
know within the team because you bought
skills but you bought one and I think
these guys would agree thank you very
much second second the head exactly but
I mean the environment I mean that's
possibly one the reason and correct me
if I'm wrong but you brought a personal
trainer with you because I know that you
knew about but exercising that
exercising is important but for some
reason like many of us including me we
didn't do it regularly yeah or for a
long time probably zero of that or next
to zero so there is a reason you wanted
to have someone to help you be next to
you and to do that I almost resent it
trying to because I felt like I know
what they're gonna say they're gonna say
exercise more and eat less like we all
know what to do to live a healthy life
and to be fit you know that that reminds
me sorry for interrupting interesting
story you know we know all what to do
what to do we all have ideas and you
mentioned about bringing me here to your
team to help and develop marketing and
content marketing do you remember how
did we first connect online remember
this moment
I think someone tagged you yes I wish it
was the person I will find out we need
to chat I'm gonna print screen I've got
a principle we need to definitely share
the person yeah we can but what you are
looking for for for videographers
content creators to join the team
full-time and I reply that to that
person hey thank you for tagging me
opportunity I'm not interested this
stage I'm not looking for a full-time
job because I run my agency but if
Samuel is interested in creating some
content getting some value from me let's
talk and you is that then later you
mentioned that you couldn't ignore it
because I mentor like Gary Vee yeah and
Warren Buffett correct and when you said
we all have we all have ideas and we all
know we all know how to do but we don't
execute it brought a thought to my mind
where I'm first time I met Gary and I
had a an had a t-shirt saying ideas are
shaped wrong and then there's you know
micro letter says like without execution
yes we all know but we have plenty ideas
like how many times you went to a store
or maybe maybe even in you know or your
students when they taught about property
and then they saw it someone else did
this deal so I think it's a child I mean
anyone can give you a great idea but the
it but these steps the implementation
that I know the reason I had to reach
you're right but that this shows the
power of branding see a lot of people
responded to that quadratus and said I
can do freelance I can do part-time I
can do and I was like ignore ignore
ignore cuz I wanted someone full-time
and I did get someone full-time but then
when you messaged number one you were
courteous and your message was
sweet message but then you mentioned
don't be able to do full-time but I'd
love to be involved and I think you
researched me as well you check me out
yes I yes we had a conversation at this
dinner the other day and and I did
because I'm you know going back to what
we talked in at the beginning about you
know the time flies and like we all have
one life and I am fortunate at this
stage of my life to to have enough work
and to work as an agency with clients
that I want and can can choose so I
really want to spend my time and energy
because I believe that you know like the
time zone the only thing we have so the
fact that we are sitting here should be
valuable to us to the viewers and
listeners to you and me because time
flies we can never get a backlog you
have kids I've got a little boy as well
and we should we should we should value
that so in fact when I messaged you so
regimented in and you said and you said
I've worked with Gary Vaynerchuk Warren
Buffet and I'd love to work with you
some of you moved out before time before
how can I ignore that so I messaged you
on Facebook and said let's nothing a
coach on Facebook and you said my wife
has just today yeah had a baby
yeah today I'm sure it was the same day
yeah it must have me like 24 to 48 hours
and I remember exactly but I remember
and I was like dude call me back in a
few days relax your first kid and you
fell back and then and then here we are
but I think when we have our first
Meetup you know one of the things that
really struck me about you I think was
just great was just you you took time to
understand the business you know and
you've actually taught me to be a better
listener and I used to got a lot of them
comments on these on these videos people
used to say oh you don't listen to
people yours interrupt people I probably
still interrupt people a little bit
sometimes but I don't get those comments
so much anymore because I've listened
some more viewers but also seeing your
example because I'm into thinking RAF so
really we'd go out for dinner and you'd
ask me questions and just listen nothing
dude man this guy he's you know got a
real gift of communication to be able to
listen and then I adapted that so thanks
to you you know for
for that sign of things what he touched
me a little bit because everyone will be
itching to know about your story of
working with Gary Vaynerchuk and how
that happened and also where you come
from and you know just a little bit
about that so maybe share some
inspiration yeah let's make it three all
right so I you know I kind of started on
that already but believe me or not
Samuel but it brings it brings me to the
time when I was a kid you know eight ten
twelve when I was a baby a kid and then
teenager I saw my my parents who you
know her great who did the best they
could but they were you know going to
day jobs in most cases they didn't like
it it was in Poland it is important so
yes I I was born in Poland I moved to
the UK around twelve thirteen years ago
so I was in Poland I was raised over
there I saw my my parents struggling
with life like with finances and you
know saying you know my manager or boss
said this or that and I thought you know
and then these kind of influence the
life as well because if you're not happy
in your in your business or they work
you know we are humans we have you know
one emotion one heart brain in
influences the family and relationship
so I thought you know how how can how
can we do how can I do it different how
can I do it better so I don't have to
complain and struggle as they did so
when I was maybe 15 or 16 I I knew that
there's something that sits in our head
and then I found out there's something
called psychology so I googled this
world this world I Google this world
online and they start started reading
about psychology that will self
development about NLP about about you
know communication skills and I as I
told you before I you know I went to a
lot of different seminars and and
learned quite a lot but then we see the
life taught me the real essence you know
fast falling you know five six seven
years later I got I got interested in in
in in camera in in taking pictures and
videos I just remember our our our
friends like Gaussian and pure they got
a digital camera set to like you know
black and white mode and you know took a
photo and now most photos look much
like oh that's cool you know I bought a
camera I started taking photos making
videos and long story short I I moved
into freelancing and then I left my day
job and started making videos and then I
discovered a personal line his name is
Gary Vaynerchuk like most of us this guy
for anyone who doesn't know Gary
Vaynerchuk he's poor he's probably he's
probably the most influential social
media person who talks about business
marketing and things like that I would
say definitely up there
I think he's got like I don't know how
many like 6 million YouTube subscribers
or something in millions on most
platforms yeah so he's he's massive and
and that and again like and I've seen
the video you sent to him of yourself
yes like no one pretty much no one I
feel like five people is what a great
way to get someone's attention
yeah you just you know you just peak to
become me stuff many video skills and
then I come a bit later but yeah exactly
so I've you know I I like creating
videos and then I my day job and my
feeling were kind of 15 I said you know
I cannot do both because one kind of
kills the other the left day job and
started doing you know freelancing that
mixed up mainly here yeah you might
because with you know running your own
business whereas if you know what is
freelancing many years ago or having a
team and being responsible for people
like we are now you're in your business
me in mind it's AB it's a big step
mentally hundred percent but then I just
you know algorithm showed me a Gary
Vaynerchuk I was like hey this dude is
really interesting because you know a
new man carries well personally because
you and you know you spend time with it
yeah exactly exactly so we know him not
only from online environment but from
from a life yeah vironment
and I basically you know he he he was
born in Belarus when he was like fears
old him of the states with his family
then you know his father open a wine
business and when he was a teenager he
started to start to grow it and then you
know became known online but he was
based in New York I'm based in London
I'm thinking you know there's no way I
can do anything for him for him he's a
great guy but you know I'm in London
New York is New York I've got a fan
here and wife but then when he opened or
announced opening an office in London I
thought and then my mind went I like
creating content like making videos I
know where's the attention of people and
I want to work with Gary Vee and he's
moving to London III start thinking how
can i connect these two puzzles yeah and
then I went to one of one of his events
he was invited there's a video online I
think it's a yeah I think it's been
organized by the drama like a company
called the drama in East London and they
invited him there he spoke there I went
there and long story short I raise my
hand and ask him a question
hey asking two questions one was kind of
a business slash you know family related
the other one was hey Gary I would have
to would love to create some content for
you want to be your dear Rocky in the in
the UK in Europe making videos and he
said hey RAF great but send me an email
and let's see what what we can do and I
thought okay I will do that but like
Samuel how many people approached you in
person or online like you know hundreds
all the time so if you and as far as I
know we never say like no no no what you
say you know sending emails and new
message would be a home that you're
unable to respond to do it on your own
Gary had the same story so he just says
to everyone send me a message send me an
email and I knew that if I send just an
email it may or may not work because
thousands of people emailed him so I got
home the same I got home the same night
and rather making an email of I'm
thinking how to get out of the box how
to make it a bit different I thought you
know if I want to do a video let me do a
video so I started my living room put
like three four cameras around
microphone light and that's the video
you've seen I literally spoke to camera
for 10-15 minutes and edited that it
down to like three minutes CV and I send
it but what's important that probably
goes back to to my tattoo here is that I
think speed and making things happen is
really important in life for everyone
within your business in mind because the
event with Gary finished around 910 p.m.
I got home
eleven like what can I do what can I do
Gary Satya send me an email
but do I just say hey Gary we just met
and let's I want to do the video for it
that's like I I thought that there was
something more that I can yeah so I made
this video
long story short five five am I finished
the video and I try it
I edited in the Excel and examples of my
work so so after someone sees the three
minutes piece they know pretty much
everything about me from business and
create create or point of view and my
wife woke up around 6:00 a.m. and I was
going to sleep she was like oh my god
you crazy
Roth go to sleep long story short few
days later I got an email saying hi raft
you know the work is great we love to
work with you and and I was invited to
me to Gary you know 6 or 7 a.m. along
the hotel understand days with him and
then more more video more content came
over so that's pretty much that
that's pretty much the story us awesome
and I think speed of implementation
perseverance putting yourself out there
being unafraid to be rejected all of
these things what you did resulted in
you landing the opportunity and you also
set up something similar in our company
which is the hash tag hmm I want to work
for Samuel leaves because I was getting
lots of people and you set this hash tag
up and now we've actually I think we
took Adam on from the hashtag yes Adam
and new and new and path one of the
videographer to the camera path Wow
so if anyone's watching this thinking
how can I approach garyvee maybe do you
what go to this event do something books
both if you want to work within within
our company put something crazy out
there show you skills and put the hash
tag I want to work for Samuel leaves and
we'll see it correct and it is great
will someone be charged exactly and
exactly listeners and viewers if you
want to work for Samuel it's great but
if you if the recent viewers want to do
something for a celebrity someone that's
known online to do the people need to
get their attention
yeah because this way there is like came
up with this in our strategy of I want
to work for Samuel Leeds is that someone
or creator in order to be involved or be
interviewed has to create something
which is
she has to create something which which
means that the person would put work in
the first place like how many people say
now there's no way I would create
something because I don't know what will
happen next
yeah and those people are ready rejected
that's a poor mentality yeah
rich people always think in terms of
serve first add value first money
follows most poor people are on the
money on the money
it doesn't work like that that's not how
it works in business like you give free
consultations you write free books
you've got I put on free crash courses I
have free and then you know that the
follow up what you good karma is gonna
happen so in fact even Emilia she got
the she landed her career here I saw a
video she poked you up over the oil so
putting yourself out there you know do
podcasts do you have a podcast yeah I
have a podcast you know having a podcast
is it put yourself out there do videos
is a smart thing exactly and it's a part
of strategy so that kind of brings me to
another question obviously you you've
created so much content over the years
you know but and and it's funny because
I'm I'm just currently will be
publishing and maybe when we when people
listen to this to this video they will
live now but basically my new agency
website will based on three pillars
strategy production and distribution the
reason I'm saying that is because a lot
of people think that's only about
creating content but if we don't know
what's the reason behind it we cannot
get s as big results yeah so let's talk
for a second about the strategy you know
why in years ago did you start on
YouTube why did you why do you think
that talking to the camera the right way
to go why did you start there I stopped
you know whatever happened so oil
storage I actually I actually set up a
business networking group called
training gangs and I was burning you
know business Network meetings and
sessions people also asking me about
property and I started I ran a couple of
small workshops
and the business cards out if I'll pass
packaging selling deals so I grew a
little list and I had a CRM system which
was actually a free CRM system called
MailChimp which is a place where you put
all your emails on and then you can send
it like a newsletter and have this set
up and I thought well if I want to be
sending a newsletter I need to put some
something in it of value yeah so I could
either do a blog but then I'm gonna have
to type something up and I thought it's
gonna be quicker for the video so what I
did was when I was viewing houses I just
kept my phone out I'd do a little video
hey what's up this is for the people
that are on my list and I wanted to
share what I'm up to I'm Vee in this
house and and I just document what I was
doing and then send it out as a
newsletter but once I once I've done it
once I'd filmed it I needed to upload it
somewhere in order to send them a link
and I did I just uploaded it on YouTube
what started freaking me out was after
about six months of doing these videos
and sending them to my list I probably
at about eight or nine hundred people on
my list
that's like Dickon my videos are
sometimes getting like three thousand
views how can I be getting more views
yeah then the people on my list
holy-moly people are finding me
organically from YouTube lightbulb
moment that was and that was when I
thought what actually these YouTube
videos aren't for my existing audience
they're actually also going to be
growing a new audience so I started you
know kind of committing to do YouTube
videos more regularly started in one a
week one or it went to three a week
which went to five a week which was to
one day day and it's the first couple
years I was just doing on my phone yeah
and then I hired neck when me Russell
formed only a couple years ago
well Nick was working for Russell as a
videographer so Nick came across which
was for me like a real relief and then
Nick decided he wanted some teammates
and we took on more videographers and it
just grew and that's how I wanted but
that's that's where your strategy came
in like you you wanted to send profile
you give value to your newsletter
subscribers there was a reason for that
yeah that's why strategy
yeah and then and then distribution of
seconded production is oh we could speak
for you know it's a mid-afternoon now we
can speak till till midnight but yeah
content production distribution you you
do like to speak to the camera and you
what advice could you give as a you know
as a creator to someone that wants to
start doing that because a lot of people
currently we have you know fancy
microphones couple of cameras lights
what do you what do you you know how do
you how do you start you know we're in
2020 if you were to start today with
common production what would you do
Samuel oh just your honor that in fact I
did my identity is like this with people
in in rooms like this well I just got
the phone and I put it on a box and it
was just about in the position where you
can see both of us one angle press
record
talk for half an hour publish it to
YouTube was the recording good no was
the sound good no lighting no content
yes people bet just gritted their teeth
and watched it for the content did it
enjoy the sound quality but they'd watch
it but that's how it started yeah so I
mean and also the biggest problem people
have that want to be influences and get
started marketing and putting videos out
is being a perfectionist
mhm you know because ultimately you're
gonna get better as you go it's never
gonna be a ten out of ten video on the
first time around but if you do the
video or most people lose the Shuar
video they go nice no good the shoot
again the shoot it again the shoot again
and then they put the ninth video out
but in that time you could have just put
nine videos exactly done is better than
perfect correct done is better than
perfect and great bang on one or two
more question I'm I'm kind of a geek and
a techie hat as well yeah and we know
where's today today's attentions of
people are people are it's here it's on
our mobiles and mobiles do have apps
it's question I asked when I interview
people on my podcast or or or doesn't
you know friends what are the you know
three top apps use on your phone if you
were to like open and look at it or even
you can go to like settings
you said there was a I'm just
interesting you know people may be
interested what Samuel is using on his
phone okay YouTube yeah that's not a
surprise
Safari okay and what's that okay
is it based on the stats or you think
about you you think it's it's just the
top three that I have at the bottom I
was going to ask that yes exactly
yeah that's interesting one last
question I like to ask people what's
what the purchase that you made over the
last six six months of a hundred pounds
or less that influence you a lot or you
you enjoy something small that you
bought that you like maybe give give it
gave it to someone as a gift there's
something come to your mind man I had a
gift actually I had a mug from Amelia
okay and it said on it if you were
everybody's cup of tea you may as well
be a mug I don't know how much the mug
cost but I thought it was a really nice
little gift so and and I'd say that was
probably something that brought a smile
on my face the last few months
oh wow what's new in Samuels Leitz Wars
in 2020 what's coming what's coming big
deals
so rather than buying lots and lots and
lots of some more houses I've decided
that I'm going to scale up and do bigger
deals I'll be documenting that finishing
the castle renovations in 2020 which is
just going to be fabulous and a lot more
people becoming financially free
last year 111 people became financially
free and you're just going to begin
ridiculous success story after success
story all throughout 2020 I might even
publish a book with all of these people
yeah amazing yeah hey dude I appreciate
you coming on the show man and I
appreciate all the hard work you've done
over the last sort of six months or so
thank you very much respect your boss
some human being saying thank you thank
you so much
[Music]
you
[Music]